ich ärgere mich über die
ladenschlussgesetze in deutschland und
zwar tue ich das aus aktuellem anlass
denn wir haben in diesen tagen 25 jahre
reform des deutschen land schluss
gesetzes vor genau 25 jahren hat der
bundestag entschieden sie leben in
deutschland müssen nicht mehr um 18 30
sondern sie dürfen gnädigerweise schon
um 20 uhr zu machen und seither gibt es
eine gesetzesflut in deutschland weil
auch die bundesländer inzwischen
zuständig sind wir haben etwa vier bis
fünfhundert gesetzes verordnung allein
zum klagen schloss und der ladenschluss
ist völlig wirre und lässt sich im
alltag es gibt außen anregungen für
tankstellen für flughäfen der apotheken
für blumenläden in jedem bundesland ist
es wiederum ein bisschen anders deswegen
fordere ich schaffe sie einfach alle ab
diese gesetze es wäre ein gnadenakt für
unseren leidenden einzelhandel der am
ende der korona pandemie wirklich schwer
gelitten hat es wäre ein gerechtigkeit
akt den der konkurrenzsituation zum
online handel gegenüber denn der
online-handel der läuft einfach 24/7
durch es wäre eine wohltat für unsere
innenstädte wenn dort auch mal einen
laden und bis um 9 uhr auf machen könnte
und es wäre eine praktische lebenshilfe
für millionen von gerade jungen eltern
die arbeiten und abends nach dem beruf
noch in einem völlig überfüllten
supermarkt hetzen um noch die milch zu
kaufen also mein appell an dieser stelle
schluss mit dem laden scheiß drauf haben
das ist absolut richtig ich wünschte mir
dass einer der drei kandidaten in diesem
trio das so formuliert hätte aber warum
tun sie es nicht weil sie wissen a wir
kriegen die kirchen an die backe wir
kriegen die gewerkschaften an der backe
alles was sie gesagt haben ist richtig
alles ist logisch aber ich glaube nicht
dass ein politiker den mut hätte das
sozusagen die kirchen beispielsweise ich
bin mein leben lang ohne zu fragen um 10
uhr ein kindergottesdienst marschiert
weil man da hinzugehen hatte ich bin der
meinung wenn die kirche sagt die läden
müssen zu sein und wenn jemand nur
deswegen in die kirche geht weil er
nicht einkaufen gehen kann dann müsste
die kirche auf den gerne verzichten
können weil wir sagen der würde
normalerweise einkaufen gehen weil er
nicht weiß wohin er soll geht an die
kirche das ist doch quatsch und ich habe
in amerika ohne hier klugscheißer über
jahrzehnte hinweg überhaupt nicht mehr
daran gedacht haben die leben auf oder
nicht du bist einfach wenn du was
braucht das dahin marschiert und da
saßen keine verzweifelten verkäuferinnen
sonntag die motive oder was es da bei
uns alles auch gab so dieser angstfrei
kennwort aber das sind grundsätzlich
völlig andere gesichtspunkte es gibt
eine werbung in amerika da ist eine
erkennbar 70 jährige bedienung die sagt
firework n walk again das arthritis
mittel hilft dir also sie kann wieder
die tabletts fragen da sagt unser einer
aus der 1 wir kommen um gottes willen
bleibt zu hause und wo hört es auf also
dass man sagen kann jeder soll so lange
arbeiten wie er will egal ob er antritt
ist hat oder nicht jeder soll seinen
laden aufmachen waren er will und da
kommt wieder die ordnungspolitik ins
spiel was wollen wir und das sind für
mich politische sachverhalte die ich
gerne von einem politiker erklärt haben
möchte oder b gefordert haben möchte wir
sitzen hier und sagen ja das muss doch
mal einer machen und keiner was machen
warum nicht sinn würde es aber macht
doch ich glaube wenn wir eine
ampelkoalition bekommen wird des
ladenschlussgesetzes in deutschland
realisiert ja ja das haben sie mir das
war eine hoffnung und nach dem heutigen
appell sowieso das hat er mit
politischer führung und in führung
bedeutete der prioritäten setzt ja da
muss manches was wichtig was wichtig ist
getrennt werden von dem von weniger
wichtig und ich finde das wichtigste
hier in der in diesem land schutzgesetz
ist die verweigerung der kunden
zentrierung kunde ist könig und das
landschaftsgesetz ist eine antiquierte
vor reflektiert eine antiquierte
vorstellung
meinte reflektiert eine antiquierte
vorstellung von von
einer dienstleistungsgesellschaft ja der
kunde ist könig und das ist ja im
online-handel ja und wenn ich jetzt sehe
ich bin ja selber interessiert der börse
online
hier schafft wenn ich sehe mit welcher
freude die jungen leute daran arbeiten
dass alles zu präsentieren dasselbe kann
man kann man im stationären handel auch
machen und wenn heute über die
konkurrenz mit dem zwischen
online-handel und stationären handel der
gesprochen wird das quasi der
online-handel zu einer verödung der
innenstädte führen würde weil daneben
viele geschäfte sich doch noch nicht
belohnen und würde das einzige mittel da
rauszukommen ist genau das was da vor
ladenschluss weg alles auf alles mit
guter laune und die leute bummeln dann
halt bis neun uhr abends ja und fühlt
sich endlich mal die commission
dasselbe wie gefangen in unseren
reglements bin denn die komplette
freigabe sozusagen jeder kann öffnen
wann er will habe ich mir in der
klassischen form noch nie vorgestellt
finde ich in interessanten für diesen
interessanten punkt mich beschleicht so
eine leichte sage ob das nicht gut ist
für die großen stärkeren und schlecht
für die kleinen
ganz kleinen warum gleich um sowie sehen
in new york london sie ist es eine eher
die kleinen die davon ja ja aber
ich würde sagen lasst doch die kunden
entscheiden also ich würde für eine
novellierung des gesetzes seien aber so
mit probezeit also ein jahr ist ein
untersuchungszeitraum und dann gucken
wir uns an ob sozusagen die komplette
offenlegung
eröffnungs möglichkeit stärker ist und
größeren impact auf die gesellschaft und
die wirtschaft als verachtung als das
ritual ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut
dass sonntag nicht die gleiche hölle los
ist wie montag und mittwoch
das regelt der markt ja deswegen sage
ich ja das ausprobieren ja was während
die männlichen scheint wieso muss ja was
noch da ist
die hässliche fratze
regulieren das
deutsche nein aber ich sag dir gefällt
eingereichte sorge
ja und das zweite ist lasst uns
das richtig machen straße staatlichen
regulierung ja warum lassen wir jetzt
haben ja jetzt sagt das ja begeben da
jetzt irgend einem 5 4 gegen ein okay
ich überzeugt bei einer sache
beispringen ich bin zwar auch sehr ich
sehr für den freien markt aber mit einer
sache ist in amerika ist es system ja
auch anders dann müssen die menschen ja
auch wirklich noch viel stärker arbeiten
gehen als bei uns ich liebe den american
dream den american way of thinking aber
ich bin manchmal schon ganz gut das ist
bei uns nicht ganz so krass ist und ich
frage mich dann hält schon was ist dann
mit den leuten mache ich meine wenn man
in einem hoch dotierten job irgendwie
von montag bis sonntag arbeitet dann
sage ich mir meine ja die leute werden
gut entlohnt aber was würde es dann
machen mit den mitarbeitern die er schon
für geringe löhne arbeiten jetzt habe er
spaß gehabt mit mir weil ihr gesagt habe
der kunde der kunde der kunden der
würste mit dem mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter wissen das
hotel ich hab doch nichts sagen ich
mache die ware um 11 wozu weil ich jetzt
ja
das ist doch nicht die einzige
dienstleistungsbranche hier sei es gibt
immer situationen solchen sowie bei
hartz4 die einen wollen raus die anderen
richten sich ein bei verkäuferinnen wir
kennen das alles aus den kaufhäusern die
geradezu die flucht ergreifen wenn so
eine frage gestellt und anderen die
kommt eben sagt ja es ist die
persönliche attitude des einzelnen und
es gibt verkäuferin wo man sagen kann
danke danke hier will und ich gehe mal
kurz endlager gucken und ich habe ihre
größe wenn sie nicht da ist es gibt
solche und entschuldigung dass ich
gestört habe das ist das management
es gibt bundesländer da dürfen die
bäcker am sonntag nur soundsoviel
stunden und machen die kaffee ist aber
den ganzen tag jetzt erklären sich die
bäcker zu speisen anbieter und wollen
das vor gericht ein klang ist prüfen
richter ob ein belegtes brötchen eine
speise ist oder nicht und ein café
ähnliches geschäft das doch alles ab so
jetzt habe ich es vor das war also in
der korona zeit nur eine fortschreibung
dieses unsinns das quasi der uhren der
uhren laden auf der einen seite der
straße schließen musste aber der
bücherverkauf buchladen auf der anderen
seite offen halten also sozusagen das
heißt aus dem verrückten
ladenschlussgesetz hat sich die absurde
corona genau weil ich jetzt ganz
abstrakte mit ganz abschaffen überlegen
so viele leben die auch schon bis bis
mitternacht auf haben ja und dort
findest du auch gut gelaunte
dazu da fehler dann zwei stunden
verdienst aber so seine sache
abzuschließen ich bin ja
aber würde da nicht andere
dienstleistungsbranchen wie zum beispiel
der friseursalon und co noch viel mehr
helfen also für mich wäre das eine große
erleichterung wenn ich hier nach vielen
nach 18 friseur na klar
da heißt der laden schutz friseurladen
des typs eno abends die haare schneiden
dürfen es waren halt vielleicht
also erstmals in hongkong um mitternacht
bei einem friseur es war außerordentlich
unterhaltsam ja und die vorstellung dass
ein staat herkommt und den menschen dem
friseur und dem chronischen vorschreibt
du darfst das nur zu bestimmten uhrzeit
die ist doch absurd stellt euch mal vor
wir würden das im internet machen weil
aus irgendwelchen gründen wir der
meinung sind es muss stunden geben wo da
nicht herein regulieren
[Musik]